let's go next to our caller from the
2:03 area code who's calling today from
2:03 hey David hey this is Josh hey Josh
what's up my question today is based on
the polling and based on I guess past
elections and everything that you can
tell about the current crew of
Democratic candidates yes which do you
think realistically has the best chance
of defeating Trump
I know Luthan polls or I guess all of
the polls have shown Biden to be number
one just but that seems to be a lot
based on him having the greatest name
recognition and every time he seems to
beat his numbers go down a little bit
yeah so where do you think who do you
think has the best chance is it one of
the more progressive candidates someone
like Bernie or someone more closer to
the center so listen I'm I'm not
pretending to have any one of these you
know sometimes people will call me and
they'll say Dave I got a call last week
in fact from someone who said David
listen it doesn't matter what the polls
say Andrew yang is the only person who
can actually beat Trump everybody else
would lose but Andrew yang would defeat
Trump and then I say well what data do
you have to back that up and they say
none I just think that that's the way it
would shake out okay I'm not gonna do
anything like that what I can tell you
is the following at the national level
there's a lot of Democratic candidates
that are polling well against Donald
Trump this includes the top three
Bernie Warren and Biden now we know that
in the United States elections don't
typically come down to or let me put it
a different way elections are often
decided by a number of key states what
the so called swing state states like
Michigan and North Carolina and and
Florida in other states so when we look
at the hypothetical matchups in those
states that in 2016 made a difference
Trump and I'm sorry Biden and Bernie
seemed to do the best against Trump in
those key states Elizabeth Warren the
New York Times had a piece about this
did less well in those key states so
that's what I go by I go who looks like
they have a shot at the nomination right
now Biden Bernie
Warren you know does Buddha jej I don't
know he popped last week but now he's
back down of those three candidates it
seemed and I like Elizabeth Warren it
seemed as though Warren was the weakest
in some of those key states so I I just
go by the data we have at the time yes
yeah that that all makes sense to me I
mean I remember in 2016 they were
showing sort of those head-to-head
matchups between Hill this is during the
the primary snow but between Hillary and
Trump and then between Bernie and Trump
and there was a big difference I mean
Bernie was you know double digits and a
lot of these polls where Hillary was
only winning by a few points which ended
up you know she had ended up holding
that but obviously the electoral college
you know we get a little bit different
but do you think there's value in
looking at the at those head-to-head
matchups and looking at those those key
states in the Rust Belt I do think so I
mean Democrat polls get a bad rap in
general but what you have to understand
is that generally speaking you know the
national polls in 2016 said Hillary
would win by about three what those what
that measures is national popular vote
and she did win by about three there
were states that within the margin of
error within the margin of error some
went her way and some didn't and that
you know I think polling gets a bad rap
there are certainly critiques of polls
there is momentum that a polling
snapshot at any one point in time can't
give you but to ignore the polling I
think does not make sense and we we
should look at the polls to give us an
idea of trends we should look at the
polls to give us an idea of how one
hypothetical matchup compares to another
it's not going to give us all of the
information and of course we're still 11
months away but the idea of ignoring the
polls and using you know when someone
calls up and says I don't care what the
data says Tulsi Gabbard is the only one
that can beat Trump okay well so if I
mean if you're just making claims
without evidence we can also dismiss
them without evidence they're not very
useful to us right right that makes
sense and I know there's also a little
bit of a bias in these polls because you
know they're done using rand line that's
not true so that's that it's really
important not to keep repeating that
there was a poll
that famously from CNN was an only
landline poll but for the most part look
at the methodology it's a combination of
cell phones and landlines weighted to
account for in some cases a registered
voter model based on age distribution
sometimes they account for likely voter
model but we should let's not keep
repeating that that poles only call
landlines it's not true I get called on
my cell phone for polls it let's not
repeat that because we're creating more
problems okay that's that's good to know
I didn't know that yeah all right thank
you for the call I really appreciate it
I likewise I've got a bunch of people
holding so I'm gonna let you go privacy
comm is one of our sponsors and they're
giving you $5.00 just for using their
free service at privacy comm slash
Pakman privacy's of service I've been
using for a while now I love it it saves
me a bunch of headaches it's completely
free and it's very quick to set up and
here's how it works when you pay for
something online or over the phone
instead of exposing your real credit
card number privacy lets you generate
virtual card numbers the payments are
withdrawn from your checking account but
your real card number stays completely
private and you do it all with one click
you can autofill the card number in your
web browser on the phone you can create
12 virtual cards a month you can set
spending limits freeze them delete them
whenever you want I especially love it
for free trials where you need to give a
credit card number because I can destroy
the virtual card number as soon as I
give it to the company and I know I
won't be charged in the future if you're
ordering food over the phone why do I
need to give a restaurant my real card
number I don't have to companies don't
have to know who you are your real
credit card number is protected from the
data breaches that happen unfortunately
more often than we would like and it's
completely free they do have a paid
version with different tiers where you
can create more virtual credit card
numbers per month cash back rewards
extra security features but go ahead and
sign up for the free service it's a
no-brainer companies can't charge you
unexpectedly you're protected from
identity theft it costs you nothing and
privacy is giving you $5.00 to spend
just
for signing up when you go to privacy
calm slash Pakman